hi guys no we are now live this is
exciting
yay let's see you gotta wait a little
bit it's our first time live-streaming
ever so please be patient this is a lot
more complicated I'm excited
okay so let us see hey we see the common
people yeah you guys are here we're so
excited oh my gosh this is so so so
exciting news me why can't we see
yourself can you guys be in cuz we can
see your comment but we can't do you see
ya Sam close the window Oh videos not
playing wait you're the thing no oh okay
[Laughter]
to lecture right now it's kind of like
test fit since tomorrow is the big day
and we want to make sure everything goes
smoothly so we can see all of your
guys's comments are coming in so crazy
right now yeah we can't read them all
but give me one second I'm gonna post
this link to make sure everyone else
knows that we are alive and let me see
let me see
okay one second we're alive now guys
make sure to swipe up and then you guys
can see us right now alright we'll leave
this video uh so you guys can see any of
you guys I'm catching
I know it's creating time zone change
differences okay I didn't make it you
guys need it anyway there's not much to
figure out how it is pretty intense it's
like so much stuff after yelling okay
where's I think I saw that I think it's
with my parents right now and they're
eating breakfast actually this lunch
yeah right now all right man it's so
fast congrats congrats Congrats exciting
excited heart heart heart heart heart
swag
where are you guys are you guys awake
right now how many Americans are here
there's a lot of people this must be
like a lot of Australians and Europeans
here okay all right now look good to a
wedding stuff alright waiting alright so
tomorrow we are gonna have Michael's
Katie's best friend livestream for us so
he's gonna be walking around with you
guys in his hands but he will also be
taking breaks so there will be we're
creating this like little sign to let
you guys know whenever we're recording
or like whenever you sing a break or
whatever we're about to start the stream
and in that time you know so you can get
a break and you can actually enjoy the
wedding with us cuz he is our guest as
well so we're gonna try to interact with
you guys but you know realistically
we're just gonna be you know enjoying
the entire day with that family so don't
expect us to really comment back or
anything like that but at least you guys
but the reason why we wanted a life
Summa though is so you guys can see and
feel like you guys are there with it and
then get to experience the wedding day
with us and yeah and then not only that
but we also wanted this experience for
our family
like orangey oh they couldn't make it
out so they can also be tuning in and
watching with up so they can feel like
they're here and they're experiencing
with us so as the reason why we wanted
to like shroom but yeah we're gonna be a
fun crazy hectic but exciting
they sounded nervous and excited at the
same time I actually posted this on
Instagram a couple days ago where and
actually arriving Paris I felt so crazy
I felt sick actually felt like my body
wasn't well thought like the flu was
coming over so nauseous and like stomach
cramps and it was like those kinds of
stomach cramps you give them your
nervous no and like um and I didn't I
didn't know what it was and I thought I
was getting sick but then after coming
here for a couple days and then finally
meeting up with a lot of our friends and
family here I'm talking to them seeing
their faces and just having a good time
out here that really helps settle my my
feelings now and so like I feel a lot
more calm down but I do that when I woke
up this morning knowing that today today
what we're doing a welcoming event today
so today we're doing like a whole like
can't bring everyone together because so
far we've only been able to hang out
with small groups of people at a time so
today is the first time wrapping a room
together and actually you know starting
our wedding celebration stuff today and
I'm getting nervous now yeah it's pretty
cool so what we're doing today for
everyone is we're renting up is like
double-decker bus and then we're gonna
do like entire bus tour of the city just
kind of like you know have a good time
with everyone and get to enjoy the city
and then after we're gonna have dinner
and then at that dinner is when we're
gonna tell people what to expect for the
next day for tomorrow because no one and
no one knows where our wedding is like
we haven't told anyone this nu we
haven't told them any details they're
completely in the dark right now so the
reason we did that because we really
wanted to surprise everyone with the
venue and like see their reactions and
see like how they react to it because
it's a pretty cool place so today
they're gonna
like okay well ten they're gonna get
picked up and all that stuff but yeah
I've been feeling the same way this
entire time we've been here I've been
like yeah we're getting like stomach
cramps and I like this knot in my throat
in my chest like just I'm just so
nervous but not like in the like
stressing or freaking out Pandora's it's
more of that like excited nervous and
it's like I can't wait to experience
it's kind of that feeling that you get
when you're about to go on a roller
coaster and you're just like I'm so
nervous but I'm excited and I just can't
wait to like go through with it you know
so that's the way I've been feeling too
but today I woke up this morning and I
don't feel like that I'll actually yeah
I don't know the way I've been I'm
really weird cause like even when I was
gathering me before like everything
leading up to me getting into the plane
I was I'm always like really really
really nervous but then the moment I'm
inside the plane and I'm like the doors
open I'm about to jump
I'm like really calm it's so weird so
that's how I feel right now I feel like
calm and I'm just like happy and I'm
just ready ready to select tomorrow
happen so that's how I'm feeling and
just trying to make sure everyone is
having a good time as well like when I
actually do stop slow down and think of
tomorrow downstairs we're here at this
house that we're renting all the
bedrooms are upstairs in the kitchen and
the bathrooms showers are all downstairs
so Tommy Tommy
[Music]
but we're something we're still friends
and we're still just just no guys
whoever you don't see here tomorrow they
were in my they have been like you know
and if they weren't invited so we might
have not felt like we wanted to really
burn in them because it is kind of like
a an entire trip and like I don't know
we just wanted to make sure that we had
the most the most amount of friends and
family here well yeah I guess in that
canvas I don't know but yeah just know
that whoever you don't be here tomorrow
they were invited and so yeah you know
like yeah a lot of action not a lot
actually
I mean like a third of the people that
we invited we don't blame them either
because we really gave everyone a really
short notice and by the time like we
explained us in the video before but we
had planned on getting married in
September but then finding out Gio's
pregnancy and then like we tried to move
it up ahead to see if she could try and
make it that couldn't happen but we
still stuck to the date that we ended up
changing because then in order to like
to go back and forth with everyone
because everyone's are trying to make
sure that the and our plane tickets and
everything so it was a really rushed
process though a lot of people that
could have came or a lot of people that
wanted to come could currycomb because
of the fact that it was such a short
notice
but yeah same thing with like my
family's up and so yeah but my mom is
here have two aunts that are here and my
cousin is here so and then your family
from Hong Kong and then most of them are
a friend friends are here so you guys
will see them tomorrow you guys will get
to meet everyone it's pretty fun yeah
absolutely
yeah so yeah Josh also so I know all the
comment they're gonna be like wow you
guys we did you just couldn't come back
so when the video going up so it's
tomorrow
yeah Casey there's a BBQ the whole
wedding
[Laughter]
yeah the description of this the time
and then you can figure out your time
yeah but my dad after dinner which was
all red wine we walked over to to the
Eiffel Tower to kind of joy the
nightlife in the night scene I'm at the
Eiffel Tower then which the Apple car
actually wakes up at night too so it's
pretty cool and and there's a lot of
vendors there where they're selling
champagnes and stuff like that and we
got a spot on the lawn there and you
know we laid out and then bought two
bottles of champagne and we started
drinking some and you guys know about
drinking you know you're not supposed to
mix lighted darks together so the red
one was my dark alcohol for the night
and then I should haven't drank the
champagne but we went crazy on the
champagne as well which is the light one
and so I instantly got it
at night and I'll go put another egg
this morning that's crazy
Leia all right I'm screening out this
link everyone else can join us the
flower boy nobody oh it's so cute she's
gonna be able want to give me away he's
gonna walk down the aisle with me I
can't I know it's so funny cause I feel
lovely and a nice they were like we
gotta buy some waterproof makeup they're
gonna be bawling her eyes out I'm like I
know how my I am so emotional it was
crazy I feel like the old rogue a more
emotional I get and I'm just like oh
please don't cry tomorrow I don't want
to mess up the makeup again I need to
know any we're both pretty emotional and
[Music]
I just hope that we can get through the
ceremony with that right no curium is
fine but I think it's get choked up and
just stops the whole thing very [ __ ]
fun
well you just can't get another word out
yeah you know I haven't even worked on
my every time I'm kind of thinking about
it I'm like I know what I want to say
but I don't know how to put it into
words it's so weird yeah I don't know I
when it comes to making speeches and
stuff like I mean I've made speech at a
couple weddings now my friends Barton
gos and I don't know it's like when the
moment comes you get your best
inspiration and ideas to talk about them
there because you feel it then it there
and then you get behind what you're
saying as opposed to you're writing it
you have to kind of fabricate what you
would feel like or want to talk about
prior to that happening and when you're
saying it and reciting the written stuff
to me it doesn't feel as genuine yeah
there's no emotion behind it so for me I
do like the kind of winging it but I
don't know for this so I feel like the
back-up plan maybe we should you know
write down a bullet list yeah yeah well
the points and kind of have a back-up
plan if you do kind of just know you
know last time that I wrote speech was
from my best friend's 15th birthday and
when like we just surprised there was
like a speech and my other friend she
went first and like we were just bawling
her eyes out and so bad time was my turn
obviously I can't even say anything that
I wrote so I'm like I hope that doesn't
happen
oh but yeah hey hey australia let's see
what do you guys want to know ask this
question well I saw someone asking if I
hadn't seen my wedding dress yet and no
I have not what I've seen a picture of
the wedding dress on a mannequin know
like website on the website so like the
catalog photo of it but I haven't seen
on her yet not through photos a not in
person so we're trying to keep that like
it's like is that traditional like not
seeing the bride and I see you're in
yeah well I guess another tradition that
you're not supposed to sleep in the same
so that Parton thing would be
traditional but we will be getting ready
like in the same house but like
separately and then I'm not going to put
my dress on until we get to the venue
and it's pretty awesome because I bought
a Chinese dress we're going to be doing
a tea ceremony but this family and my
family is gonna be like a really cool
like collision of our cultures and and
so like I'm really really really excited
to show everyone my Chinese dresses I
love it so much but oh with it thank you
Lord flack oh wait the best from Sweden
thank you so much you're so awesome
there are no brightening honeymoon
you guys will find out where we're gonna
go secrets I like it I like it because
it's more like you know I don't even
though it's not really okay we want to
be adopted all right he wants to be
adopted uh-huh
Oh Papa tan they all went out to eat oh
thank you GM you said I look pretty
beautiful with brown hair
best man no best man right there best
man there's no official best man
everyone was the best man here yeah
that's one thing I don't like about some
some traditions and I feel like I want
to get past certain traditions dude I
don't think that's very fair that
different moments in your life you have
different best man you know like I have
a brother and obviously throughout how
hood and my drought just life in general
like he's gonna be my best man but then
I get other times in my life you know
going to college when I left home you
know I met friends and you know
different people in my life that came in
and really held me about certain parts
of my life and so you can't really put
like a hierarchy I got I don't want to
put our key on that you know and I know
this life and like you know I don't know
it's just a weird thing I don't like
that tradition so we don't have a best
man and we are Native ronamayk made of
all right yeah yeah I felt exactly like
I've had multiple girls in my life that
would deserve that
no title but I just I wanted I just
didn't want to give it to anyone because
I'm just like you know like everyone
here is just part of the wedding we
don't want to give certain people
specific roles or like stressing them
out with something so that's what we
just we didn't have like a wedding party
or anything but yeah let's see what else
we work on baby chance
[Music]
[Music]
let's kiss they're gonna be fries mommy
answer that one please kiss kiss kiss
you see that it's not really fast eyes
though okay thank you meant oh hi oh
thank you so much for watching guys that
you guys are like sacrificing your sleep
for us thank you so much it's so fast no
I wish I could read it every single one
you know what we're just going to go
back one thing so we're gonna leave this
video up or you know like a good maybe
your whole day until tomorrow stream and
then we'll delete this one and you guys
watch 21 and then we can and then we can
like in that time we'll try to read all
your comments
I mean you guys know that Bart I mean
with Barton Gio's wedding he created a
like a really beautiful wedding video
which we are hiring a videographer as
well so we will be having an official
wedding video but yeah I'll be there
yeah it's funny Michael isn't helping us
with this whole like technical thing so
thank you Michael he's sitting behind a
camera okay but yes David is gonna be
here and yes you will be marrying
[Music]
carboys gonna do the wedding but I'm
really into that bite right now or not
because like I'm a big box inner and
it's a really cheesy thing FEA Connor
yeah I just reported in you then huh
yeah yeah so what do you guys think my
wedding hashtag should be we were
actually thinking about that too we're
thinking like Tiff's case Paris weddings
if case wedding Paris and then we were
think you're like teasing me but then it
kind of looks like it's nothing I don't
know do you guys have any ideas where
should we make our wedding hashtag baby
can you guys Thank You Vanessa you know
it's awesome
everywhere that we travel like yeah in
Japan and Hong Kong like here anytime
you go international yeah every time we
always leave the dirty of fan art
Australian Australians travel more than
American baby I don't know we never run
to American fans when we travel
internationally but internationally
I never know that you can you can like
pop them out like that what are you guys
doing to do that but oh cool you're
living in China that happen what is
Mandarin sound like what if it Mexican
accent hashtag dip your cave hashtag oh
you guys with hashtag they're just
coming in because of the delay they're
kind of going to XK to XK okay dude you
just gotta stop just chicken just that
you keep them over the whole chat yes I
am getting my makeup and hair done
Angie my homeboy Gary gonna do it she's
go out here for the wedding
so awesome and we did already have
because I saw something I popped up
really fast
the stag party which if that means like
bachelor party right yeah we had it all
we gotta tell you guys okay so it was
amazing
so the girl how I hate you song it was
amazing no it was pretty awesome we had
the greatest friend ever we feel so
lunch so what happened was it was the
day before fourth of July so July 30 all
the girls took me out to go have dinner
and then all the guys took him out to go
have dinner and during that dinner they
kept trying to get as strong and I just
barely even anything that day so I just
kept trying to like wait for the food
before I drink more alcohol and move
very very bad decision on your part
why not eat and wait no I didn't do that
on purpose
I was I was waiting for the food to
drink yeah so then the girl they kept
telling me like hey come on you're
babysitting that champagnes out or
shopping and I'm like no money for the
food and then till finally the food came
it just kept buying me all these drinks
and I'm like okay screw it is my
bachelorette party I'll try to get
cannot have a good time
so then dinner and no one's telling me
anything I think that the nights over so
I'm like bye guys bye and then you know
I hear Julia say something like hey Oh
are we gonna meet there I make me see
that and like she said that to someone
else and I'm like wait we're going
somewhere else
and then everyone's like Julia this
isn't so that was really but I'll they
wait huh I'm just I was so lost so then
finally after that is when we ended up
stopping to use the restroom and then at
that place that we saw that somebody
seen Gina she couldn't make it out Oh
berries any get that excuse my group
bathroom excuse that's good yeah
so then finally we walk into the
building where we were and I'm still so
confused on like what is its where are
we I just able to move a waiting line
and then we cross like that we passed
through these doors and I see like a
little stage to the right and then a
left was like a bar and into like the
corner and the far right I see all the
guys I'm like surprising isn't like a
co-ed bachelorette bachelor in bachelor
party so that was really fun so well how
was your experience up until that one I
went to get food at this place called
salt cure in Hollywood I think I don't
know it was like purposely drove in
circles at one point so like I wouldn't
know where we were going and then we
ended about this restaurant and they
were known for their pork chops and
stuff this man had a pork chop and some
wine and a Nadine Nadine yeah
he's the biggest culprit of the night
for me and then he started buying a
whiskey shots and I think by the time
dinner was done and finished the bottle
I mean I'll be shared the bottle but
like it was a bottle of wine plus I
think like three whiskey shots already
so I left the restaurant like like
barely able to walk already and then
everyone say goodbye just like Tigers
was and so uncle is a nice dinner and
like you know I'm like I feel good right
now
mmm this is awesome later yo and see you
guys at the wedding whatever in the car
and then like sometimes everything was
blurry by then I was like kids have a
good time whatever and then he's part
yeah at the farm like I'll go over yet
and then and then everyone honey they
wasn't imaginary screws I was like I've
been a good one but there was like oh
you're just gonna come in here and check
this place out real quick all Polar's
more stuff today no and so you go in and
I realized it's like a club or something
you know they're not nightclub it's a
this is a strip club then yeah
weirdly I never seen any play anything
like this and every were greeted by like
the lady there when we walk in and
pretty soon up judging by how people are
dressed and like you know like just
textures of everything I'm like oh right
over last show and so that's pretty cool
and everyone and you know I sit down and
then immediately drinks start flying my
way again thanks Anna diamond and then
aunt Bobbie Cobra drinks - and I was
thought and he had this point - I was
telling them whiskey whiskey whiskey and
we started off with whiskey you know and
wine is also dark so I was like it
wouldn't be a bad companionship of you
know darks you know it's not the same
with in the dark alcohols I should be
okay but then I got so messed up by then
that I didn't know how to reject
anything that wasn't whiskey huh and
then and I was told this the next day
over there that like man it took me like
two days to recover but the next time I
saw everyone there something there
telling me at a certain point everyone
started by me to Keelan out and I'm like
oh no wonder what happened happened
because then I think they started buying
me tequila and I knocked back like like
two or three tequila's in a row and then
from I remember I think that's when I
started blacking out and then when TIFF
came in
I couldn't even register that they were
here I'm just like they're like guess
who's here then they've been really
Aaron's phone's on video and they're
expecting like they're expecting this
huge moment from me like oh no but then
I'm just literally what I did I did this
I go can I can see everything's blurry
so I was like neat speckles one I'm just
focused on one eye looking out I could
see more clearly hey you guys to
Brendan's like you know both of us here
and I'm like what it is like I still
didn't know as a burlesque show until it
started so I'm just like what are we
doing here I was like a comedy show or
something because like the stage didn't
really love
let's show you know what like looking
back on the photos
it literally said Monday night four left
come on on this page and I just didn't
register already pretty drunk by that
but yeah I sent it like we sat down
people just started buying more drinks
Gina told me yesterday that later on in
that night she bought us tequila shots
and I can't drink tequila like I had the
worst experience I was way too young to
drink and so that's like Tom attack me
even bike for a long time couldn't even
think of the work to collateral so I
would want to vomit so I would like
today to drink it she's like yeah you
write you down didn't I like I must have
been really drunk I remember that and
like the fact that I could even take it
was just crazy but after that I just
remember getting there you were just
gone my consciousness is like time
traveling you would skip like like every
like 20 minutes it was just kind of skip
it although I'm here now I'm doing this
now how cool like I don't know I think
by the time I saw the first burlesque
dance like like the first performing
came up and I watch them oh cool
alright stay focused you know which is
kind of like I don't know it's like it
was blacked out and like come back in
and then by the end of that the second
performer came in I was like I can't
hang no more and I just blacked out and
then the next thing that I remember was
me going oh and I threw my Elise Borden
group into my own hand
bad news my mind was thinking like like
deep down there's like a conscious part
of me I'm like alright we gotta get out
of here ASAP is how I'm gonna explode on
everyone in here right now and so I was
like alright we got to get out of here
but my body and like the rest of my
brain was like man that one person my
family my body my brain was like just
chill and sit there and then that lovely
though I think the demon bar saw and
somebody might immediately rush me ah so
we were on the demon Bart
they were the but they were taking care
of us like
the whole night they took us home and at
home they even laid out like pots for us
to throw up and we couldn't make it
upstairs we ended up sleeping in the
living room we were just gone
it was so bad but yeah I remember like
he ran out the entire area and I was
just like well where do you go and then
at that point that's when they pulled me
out to the stage and they had like the
host dude like handed up doing like a
magic trick with my engagement ring and
I was like no and I just remember I
remember all of that that was fun and
then I don't remember what happened
after that but then next thing I
remember is they pull me up on stage
again and they were like well usually
this is when we'll have a lap dance for
the couple but the groom is out and so
she was asking me like what like who
would you want to bring up and then
that's not the first quick like I just
immediately thought gee oh and some
gypsy moths on stage and then though we
had a good time on stage it's a lot of
fun and then after that that's when I'm
recording the restroom I was throwing up
too and then I just kept apparently I'm
that kind of drunk that's always like I
love you and I love you good everyone
was like she's not just we drunk and
then I guess like he was throwing up in
the street once the whole show was over
and like we have videos of us like just
wasted which I'm sorry guys but you guys
will never see that that's private stash
there but that was pretty fun and then
the next morning we ended up recording a
video it was fourth of July trying to
recover from the worst hangover ever and
I just made a video in case he was like
crawling up the stairs and I was just
like thanks guys it was a great night
but it was a really fun fun time we had
up the best like bachelor bachelor party
ever
yeah that was that yeah like they were
saying you guys are the cutest drunk
people ever to be like at one point we
we were doing this I mean both leave for
something through a bunch of the floor
bar barbar outside and we had less than
[Music]
and then somehow everyone else's there
was a taco truck nearby well we were
throwing up like aunt Gina and who else
they were all eating tacos really grunts
how can you eat America vomiting oh
thanks for meza hashtag mr. or mrs. Chen
Paris wet let's light the hashtag wish
you guys the best again hopefully you
come on sturdy I wanna meet you - it's
like America but better like literally
like the culture like it's very American
life but then it's just just better and
I can't quite pinpoint how it's better
but it's just better and the food oh man
there's no like there's no like American
quality food is terrible
yeah we have too many farms that
genetically engineered food it's just
cleaner here yeah I really want to go
but uh tell us about your wedding dress
shopping
well wedding dress shopping was super
easy use one trip URI and Christina went
with me and and I'm sorry it's a
completely like okay so you're a priest
even came with me I bought my dress at I
don't granilith heard of so anthropology
has a wedding division called me Holmen
and that's where I got my wedding dress
so it was really cheap but really
beautiful and so can anyone like a crazy
designer dress I'm just like I'm not
gonna spend more like 10k plus on a
wedding dress Leah where one day so I'm
like no I am NOT doing that so I I was
just like you know what we'll just we'll
just I'll just shop something really
cute really simple easy and so it was a
very first dress that I tried on because
I fell in love with
it was amazing and I can't wait for you
guys but yeah it was a really simple
cheap dress don't expect anything crazy
extravagant it was pretty it's pretty
nice yeah I mean it winning itself is
not that extravagant I mean the most
extravagant part about it is location
but than that though it was pretty
pretty pretty done earth I would say mmm
so that was my wedding dress shopping
sprees I know you guys wanted us
I wanted me to make a video about it but
and or like you don't make more videos
about the wedding stuff and it's just we
are so like chill honey comes to the way
we literally told the wedding planner
like we saw all the work that she had
done in the past and we were like we
love it we love your taste the whole
things that you do in the wedding so
we're like just do your thing we have no
objection so we just kind of let her go
with it so whatever you guys need
it's me we all figure in France that's
our wedding planners company to it
that's how you pronounce Allah it was
like Peggy in France yeah there's like
what is it an accent on one of these I
don't know that's how I pronounce it oh
yeah I think that's how she pronounced
it - last time we came I don't know oh
yeah so that's what we didn't make any
like wedding planning videos because
it's kind of hard when we were planning
the wedding in a different country we're
not even here that's okay well the
wedding video that we did create words
like venue shopping cake Ted Newman from
our last trip so yeah that's mainly what
we did yeah yeah videos and if you
didn't see then check them out on her
Channel
so there's this livestream video and
that we're doing tomorrow and then after
that I'm thinking which I haven't
started editing and I know you guys are
waiting wanting to see the wedding video
but uh it might take
I'll try I'll try and breeze through
these exercises I can but um we're gonna
we're gonna after tomorrow we're gonna
time travel back and show you guys kind
of our preparation to the yeah Gerry :
Tina Tina Tina everything all the videos
yeah it's like waiting happening
tomorrow and then we'll probably go
backwards and show you guys us getting
ready and prepping for the trip us in
the last couple of days here in Paris
prior to the wedding and in the wedding
video
yeah but that video is going to be
different than all our other ones
because we the way we've been filming
this trip has been more like just a
little snippet hearing there because we
don't really we really wanted to enjoy
this trip with everyone that's here not
really focused too much on blogging so
that video is gonna be different
it's gonna be a little snippet in there
yeah are you guys gonna travel wrong
you're about your way no nothing I think
[Music]
doesn't accent yeah okay but we are
gonna be going to one destination I you
must use my cupboards I do yeah oh we
are going to one city in Europe for our
honeymoon but and it's you guys will
find out I guess
yeah and just check out Instagram repos
oh I've been trying to keep up with like
the Instagram story I don't use snapchat
anymore because it's just easier having
everything with one app so I just use
this your ground story so I'm gonna try
my best to have you guys involved with
us so you guys can just stalk me there
nothing wrong okay
Michael come here everyone keeps asking
for you they're like so is Michael here
is my
hello everyone
until started releases where are you
right now because I walk like I don't
know it was like at least two miles to
get you here I don't know how many
kilometers in fuel to see what it's like
and you don't get that by moving oh
you're such a traveling anyways this is
a slash left and I'm gonna go back to
behind the camera we have a delay we're
seeing all the yeah here and you will be
the one that's gonna be carrying bags
around tomorrow I mean like carry new
heaven like the live stream some stories
later master first let's focus lay here
41 minutes so hope you guys have been
enjoying this live stream so far yeah
tomorrow
nice - really gonna be an exciting
exciting day right I don't know talking
through this thing and I like I'm not
great you know hanging we gotta get into
that that's true oh yeah I know I know a
lot of you were meeting up on Instagram
the video would stay up on YouTube after
its unwind shrooming and yes it will be
on YouTube it will archive it and so you
guys can actually watch it at any time
and you don't have nice to have to watch
it like and it would be nice though so
you can really feel like you're there
and we can interact with you guys too
because we're gonna try our best
throughout the wedding day to see if we
can comment back and talk to you guys
response you guys's comment so we'll try
to get into that but yeah right down the
street it's easy so we're gonna go eat
have some lunch and then in a couple
hours we're gonna go do that bus tour
with everyone and yeah it's gonna be
awesome
today is like the beginning of the whole
wedding event mm-hmm yay so if you guys
just keep a lookout on our Instagram and
Twitter and we'll see if we can maybe
let you guys know before we start the
lecture exactly what time we're starting
so you guys can really tune in and be
there from beginning to end you guys can
join us yeah yeah awesome all right good
love you thank you so much for watching
and thank you everyone that's had their
comments pop-up I think you guys are
pain well that's crazy but thank you so
much thank you so much Michael did all
this press report so we didn't know
anything but thank you guys so much um
we'll see you guys tomorrow
and our bah-wah first I gotta figure out
how to stop this okay